O que você acha de trazer uma pessoa
para troquinha do rappi pode dar uma
treinada com a gente piada legal bacana
bom demais hein que é que você acha de
trazer uma pessoa para para nós ir dar
uma volta na praia a chamar atraindo
[ __ ] para conhecer mais usada da gente
irado irado Bom pelo que eu tô vendo a
galera tá conversando aprovar a trazer a
galera aqui a gente vou gente boa sabe
que a pessoa sabe que sabe que vai ter
que fazer a pessoa lá no meu Twitter
onde eu postei esse vídeo aqui para o
link a pessoa vai dar um RT porque não é
sorteio Nós Vamos sortear não escolher a
pessoa então você dá um RT né escrito RT
com comentário escrito assim eu devo
participar porque eu acho que aí bota lá
que nós vamos Lena aí nós clique no
perfil da pessoa a gente bota a tropa
todinha para ver ele ele João Neto o
Aniel todo mundo Bob acenei para todo
mundo procurar e todo mundo lê a gente
acha uma pessoa bem legal trazer para
passar pelo menos uns dois dias com a
gente aqui pode ser de qualquer lugar do
Brasil ou até do mundo mas nós vamos
escolher o Brasil perder ela dela tá ao
a
regra só essa só é Felipe já tô
participando é da RT lá no Twitter nesse
lugar onde eu postei esse vídeo novo
vídeo Vem Com a Gente dos fãs
gostei no vídeo
dele lá gostei no vídeo em todos os
[Risadas]
ela tá participando e merece participar
Você vai estar por aqui eu tô achando
que a gente vai pegar uma pessoa de cada
área entendeu a pessoa para pessoa a
pessoa que luta para treinar luta com a
gente e tudo mais fazer de tudo vou
fazer mais uma pesquisa aqui para ver se
a gente vai te aceitar pensa aqui no
verde todo dia eu tomo 2 copos de se não
é ruim não é bom você bota muita laranja
legal é um é sobre todos não é também
não é
O que
é bom para é verde é bom né É
e eu em Vamos fazer um treininho aqui
hoje eu vou fazer um pouquinho de
escolinha de combate bloqueio resposta
depois vamos sair na mão e fazer spahi
que é uma simulação de luta mesmo que a
gente faz bota os Ramos que a gente vai
fazer na luta faz como se fosse a luta
mesmo porradaria e
[Música]
E aí
e tu tá mais não para Danilo Adriane
Adriane faz Capela aí as contas lá então
no caso
finalização também né que ela Desenrola
o jiu jitsu também primeira a primeira
luta profissional foi 2014 oito anos
oito anos Pronto foi aqui não tem
Comparar as duas coisas ao mesmo tempo
eu não tem como parar tem que fazer uma
emprego tinha com ele rapidinho aqui
Você sabe cozinhar ou sabe que usar
algum produto específico cinco o que os
Fui
sim é que bota não costumo usar a última
agora você sabe você sabe desenhar gosta
de algum prato ou um artista especial
obrigado tá perto dele cair meu pai para
tu se fazer a pulga nela fui contratado
para fazer um pediu para eu vou encaixar
dentro do que eles tão querendo e tal aí
pode ser
nós
estamos gratos
E
aí trabalho
escrito muito sono
para quando for em conta o outro mesmo
não quis machucar né a gente direto
a primeira inclusão a segunda já direto
Hulk
aparecendo
aí que o
que nós quatro anos fazendo um
E aí
[Música]
é
bastante na cara não tem show viu não
vou na consciência começa assim lá para
o quinto nós já tá bom
[Música]
E aí
oi oi
o segundo cada luta é instalar menos ali
anos também fez uma coisa muito
diferente não hashtag pelo box mesmo que
é sabe aquelas Nessa idade fazer mas eu
espero nunca mais forte né é que os
caras são profissionais né Aí eu ponho
demais
o
JP também possui a marca puxadinho em
E aí
G1
[Música]
E aí
e
falou
assim como ele é bem mais embaixo e
[Música]
E aí
e
agora
tá entrando água Olha o que você fez
ontem ele fez o que de verdade agora se
ele me der quatro outros um é mas é isso
mesmo você vem na sequência que eu
espero que vai dar quatro não tem como o
cara faz bem positivo ladinho assim
assim assim ou café
aí só é um
E aí
[Música]
O
que é
[Música]
e
tchau tchau
[Música]
foi
agora nesse último
falei vou cair para dentro
tá
valendo a
e esse jogo que eu fico no último áudio
correndo para lá e para cá sorrindo Mas
eu disse sem sair eu vou aí a gente saiu
já isso aqui é para não
quebrar mesmo dente isso aqui é filho
adiciona aí fica firme machuca é o cinto
machucar consegue numa não quer ela não
é os dentes que é feita exatamente para
mim
legítimo também diferente daquele que
você compra em loja bota na água quente
essa no modo gente pensa que faz faz
amorzinho certinho sua casa dentária
fica volta foi feito no cliente pode
personalizar teu nome eu botei meu nome
eu tenho dente de vampiro de onça de
onça eu sou sim sou boa mas a gente não
sabe dosar não é para colocar o diário é
treino não é mas não conectar não é bem
a gente também é num queijo do outro
exatamente ainda mais lanterna ali na
cabecinha aqui na cabeça não curtiu até
mais boa e não rosto no rosto água sem
tomar nele ficar o negócio aí ela tudo
mais e nunca mais pode pegar uma coisa
aqui não só com os ovos Impacto para
você curtiu Não esquece de clicar em
gostei e voltar lá no Twitter onde eu
postei vídeo novo venda tanto e dar RT
lá para nós fazer a comunidade do PT que
tá sempre acordada na madruga para pegar
umas vezes não vir é horrível eu não
gostei comenta aí que você quer ver aqui
valeu